on a une surprise pour la demoiselle qui
est ici demoiselle qui s'appelle daniel
qu'on aime beaucoup qui a rejoint
l'équipe dernièrement daniel qui est un
magnifique arrêt non plongeant daniel
vous avez de son côté daniel je vais
chanter
si vous aimez la prestation vous
retourner
mais comment le recours bien n'est pas
ça fait longtemps que vous ne l'avez pas
fait
la symphonie du regard est avec nos
champions la paix politique vallée val
expo paris bientôt parce que bien qu on
bâille pas réparation francis côté n'en
fait d'ailleurs juré de voir mon chéri
et si tu as besoin d'un sparring il est
là mais s'attend à à daniel on a une
surprise pour vous parce qu'on sait
daniel votre vie on la dit vous habitez
sur votre maman vous avez connu trois
mecs dans votre vie ça fait 30 ans n'est
pas connu le garçon à peu près et dieu
sait que vous méritez pas ce que je vous
ai dit je vous le redis je trouve très
séduisant dans la sellerie à une pommade
minogue aux yeux de vos cheveux je ne
parle pas du reste
elle avait plein de choses à découvrir
daniel on va faire entrer quelqu'un dans
le silence daniel va se retourner elle
va voir la personne qui veut lui poser
une question on me dit même que le
fauteuil je retourne tout seul ah mais
oui il ya des moyens et je le redis à la
chaîne mais l'argent mon émission je
vais aller chercher la personne qui veut
poser une question à daniel silence
complice lentement
asseyez
merci d'être avec nous oui qu'on
applaudisse la personne et aucun bisou
merci vraiment d'éclat ça me fait très
plaisir
daniel va se retourner je peux vous dire
elle s'y attend pas du tout ah oui ça
suit c'est vraiment le fauteuil se
retourne tout seul non malheureusement
qu'est-ce qu'on attend tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces mamans que là si vous êtes à la
liste mais je les adore votre maman elle
a un sourire à laisser vous avions fait
un bisou à ce que vous allez vous êtes
resté
[Applaudissements]
j'avais voulu démarrer et elle vient
jamais nulle pas levé parce que
d'habitude vous travailler très tôt l'
l'aiment bien cette dame du soir elle
aime sortie c'est une cow boy avec koné
voilà
oui comment quel est votre prénom je
signe je sais nous l'avait dit joss
quand on sent la tension vous appelle
jose d'offres auprès de bouteilles ou
pas joss on est connu merci d'être là on
parle beaucoup mais vous aimez daniel
dans l'émission oh oui oh oui elle s'est
débrouillée se débrouille bien et moins
bien on la doit enrichir mais oui il ya
beaucoup de bien qu'il adore ça c'est
pas pourquoi quand
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi on a jugé démesuré que
tiger est ce que vous aimeriez qu'elle
qu'elle est un mari comme thierry moreau
ah oui pas mal bâti et gilles verdez
alors il est où on est pas mal aussi
enfin moi donc ça va c'est que j'aime
bien c'est avec jean-michel moeurs non
j'ai pas dire du mal de toute façon il
est parfait elle veut tellement habitué
à la victoire sont toutes les deux et un
vrai oui c'est magnifique mais
franchement moi j'ai envie d'habiter à
vis de vous trois n'a même pas qui est
loin du doigt de venir à la maison
vendue vous aurez toujours une soupe
chaude chez vous chez north n est pas
que la soupe
[Applaudissements]
alors j'y crois pas c'est c'est sur l
histoire puisque c'est pour un coach
voilà un bel âge tu me verras à la à la
tv bah non c'est pas ça peut-être
chroniqueuse de prendre la mairie est à
deux doigts sales et y avait des coulées
pub cowpens mairie veut aussi on peut le
faire un noeud plus à peu près le même
style c'est on a le même un styliste un
merci vous qu'à la plus d'humour
jocelyne allez-y vous avez une question
à poser à votre fille d'annie oui est-ce
que tu n'as pas peur que je retrouve un
homme avant toi ma fille
bonne question parce que c'est tout à
fait probable en fait rangs serrés c'est
vrai parce que moi quand un homme me
tourne autour ça qui fait son jogging
baskets la surface quand ma mère est là
mais messieurs qui lui cette photo elle
est très jolie mais vous êtes très bonne
avec est là je peux vous demander quel
âge - 86 dans un mois 86 d'être
magnifique et je crois que j'avais une
deuxième question
ah oui alors ne serait ce pas enfin le
temps de prendre ton envol c'est joli et
de quitter le nid vous savez que c'est
elle qui aimeraient que je parte
incident grave ou à caresser avec vous
mais pourvu qu'elle reste avec vous un
peu ballot et très bien et s'il vous
ramène à un mec à la maison pourrie qui
me plaisent pas mais évidemment la loi
c'est vrai nom mais j'aimerais où tout
le monde vous plaît venez jean michel
maire de prémisses on comprend rien trop
dit oui le truc est d'étudier si je me
marie si elle arrive à me caser elle
part dans sa charente maritime elle a
envie de retourner à bord de la tombe et
404 j'avais envie qu'elle quitte la
maison pas franchement si elle avait
quelqu'un oui mais j'ai envie qu'elle
trouve quelqu'un ben oui peut-être si
c'est moi je ferai ce qu'elle ferait ce
qu'elle fait rien ça c'est un amour et
daniel venu
coupez aller
on a vu
[Applaudissements]
l'amour l'amour